[Music]
[Applause]
let me bring in maurice jones drew nfl
network analyst he also does the rams
radio color analyst as well you can
follow him
uh maurice jones drew on twitter at mjd
how are you doing this morning
um i'm doing i'm doing great actually i
finally got a chance to uh
get a chance to call in and talk to you
it's been a while yeah
i and uh i appreciate you getting up
early after the game last night what
were your expectations
last night
um you know i think there there were
there were two times that obviously this
year the rams split with the the
cardinals so you saw
earlier in the year where the cardinals
were hot and
defensively did a great job of uh you
know forcing stafford off his spot and
then you know obviously getting
interceptions and then on their side of
the ball that's early in the year kyle
murray kind of took over the game you
utilized his legs running and then there
was a second time
where the rams kind of dominated from
start to finish and so
was a little concerned when you saw j.j
walk coming back and you know um
defensively they've done a really good
job vance joseph's done a really good
job of getting those guys in position to
make plays but
if you watch the cardinals down the
stretch they they struggled the last
five games so expectation was that the
rams started fast you know you probably
could jump on them and you know um get
them kind of get them out and have a
little doubt set in their mind there and
that's what they did it really started
from
the rams defense whose secondary was
banged up you're starting
some guys that are uh terrell burgess
nick scott those are core special teams
guys we ended up starting at safety for
the rams and kudos to raheem morris for
getting those guys prepared and
and eric well coming in after retirement
you know to be honest with you
um i told sean mcvay uh after the game
where i i kind of like joked around but
i was a little serious that if you guys
keep getting retired guys like let me
just let me know it's like getting shake
you know i mean like you don't have to
go too far i'm right here calling the
games for you i know the offense i've
been watching um
but no look
credit to those coaches and players for
stepping up in a huge game and and
playing really well to get that first
three and out and then get the ball and
get some big explosive plays and then
kind of start playing field position and
and go down and take the game over was
huge how important is the running game
for the rams
oh it's it's it's it's it's underrated i
think because when you see matthew
stafford and odell and cooper cup and
those guys like you're like oh they can
throw the ball but you have to
understand that offensive line needs to
go forward and they need to be able to
weigh and lean on guys they're they're a
bigger group
um they love the zone scheme and and
what what it does is it allows that that
defense to kind of play on its heels a
little bit with the play-action pass and
so
with the the addition of cam acres and
you know and like i said i said this
last night no no disrespect to sony
michelle and daryl henderson they did a
really good job this year but cam akers
comes in it looks different
and if you watch that game the rams just
look different with cam akers there with
his explosiveness his elusiveness uh and
then the way he finishes his runs like
he finishes like sony michelle um and so
when you got two guys that are gonna run
downhill and break tackles and run
through guys
it kind of it takes its toll on the
defense as you saw last night
i'd also like to say this i hope buddha
baker is okay that was a big collision
there
and there are a couple of them in that
game
and you know you saw the rams running
backs fall forward and so when you can
run the ball the way the rams did and
you could utilize the play action pass
matthew stafford had a clean pocket
pretty much all night and so and let's
not forget that they have you know uh
two premier pass rushers possibly three
with marcus golden chandler jones and jj
watt there rushing the quarterback
and i don't think stafford got touched
all night so
um
that that that tells you how important
that running game is
how does the this rams team match up
with the buccaneers
um i think they match up well i haven't
really yeah i watched the bucks last
game
and before i like to call again let's
try to go a couple games back just to
see how they're playing
um i know obviously they're they have a
lot of injuries going on there
um obviously the antonio brown situation
but
you know they still have gronkowski you
still have the goat the greatest of all
time tom brady you still have mike evans
offensively uh
supposedly we'll see if they get leonard
for netback
um
but i think they match up well
defensively for the rams they do a
really good job of stopping the run they
have a guy that can lock up with mike
evans you're gonna have to figure out a
way how you're gonna stop gronkowski
then offensively you know you you know
what the task is and i think todd bowles
and and has done a great job i think
that um
you know they're going to come on kind
of play man i was just listening to what
you're saying about the eagles not being
the
the least ready team for the playoffs or
something like that um
look you gotta get off press man in the
playoffs right people are gonna be
simple they wanna play fast and if
you're playing the buccaneers they're
gonna get in your face and try to beat
you up a little bit um and you have to
be able to protect and so it's going to
be a big part of the rams getting that
running game going and being able to
protect so that you can get these
receivers
um out in space and try to make some
plays so i think it's a good matchup for
the rams um but you got to go to tampa
and that's always tough to do to fly
east to west and or west to east excuse
me and get out there and play
play a game in a different
environment and climate maurice jones
drew nfl network analyst and works for
the rams radio color analyst and former
nfl running back you could start your
team with jalen ramsey aaron donald
von miller in his prime
all of them in their
prime do you want me to pick one yep
oh no there's no way
why how how how can i pick one in their
prime they're all dominant in their
prime you give you pick one and i'll
start a team with them
how about this give me how give me what
the rams have now right you see von
miller show up big in the game aaron
donald shows up big jalen ramsey's
covering guys making plays it's tough to
it's i don't think you can lose with
that in their prime right yeah but i'm
asking you
you're gonna start your team it's a
fantasy draft
it's tough man i i would have to you
know i'd have to say aaron donald did i
think interior pressure
is
the hardest thing for a quarterback to
deal with now you can double team them
yes
but
still the guy dominates and changes
games seeing double teams and triple
teams
um and you know what happens von miller
great job off the edge
uh when he was in his prime but a
quarterback can kind of step up if you
don't have that that pocket uh
that pocket being pushed back to him and
then if you have jalen ramsey yeah he
shuts down half of the field but if the
quarterback has five or six seconds to
throw he kind of takes that away from
them so i think they they all work
together but if i was going to pick one
it'd be aaron donald that's the right
aaron donald's the right call
yeah
he did all right there trying to put me
on the spot man you can't you can't do
that you know that's my job man i gotta
talk to those guys
i never hear this you don't have to
answer to it i never knew you to be
afraid
oh never it's not about being afraid
it's just you know i just don't like to
i don't like you know back in the day
when i was much younger i loved
confrontation
now i'm as i get older and more wise
it's more about just enjoying the peace
peace of mind okay all right if i said
jj watt or aaron donald in their prime
i'm gonna take aaron donald all day i
played jj watt in this primer
and how was that he played for the he
played for the texas he was a monster
but he played for the texas so i can't
give them no respect
[Laughter]
did you ever talk to anybody on defense
all the time
talk to him all the time yeah why
wouldn't i you know i mean i'll tell you
what i'll tell you a quick story about
j.j watt
we played them i don't forget what year
it was but one time we played him in
houston i swear it was like
we've tried to block him with seven
people he still got to the corner
and i was just like dude like come on
bro this is too much
like
there's no way there's no way this guy
is just dominating all of us right
um and so we tried to block him with
eight and that didn't work either so we
just figured we'll just do one on one
and take our chances with my guy blaine
gary back there he's got to scramble get
the ball out
blaine gabbard as your quarterback
and i get to see blaine this week yeah
it's amazing yeah look at the football
life man i get to see my guy blaine this
week got him a super bowl
you know i'm excited to learn behind tom
brady you know he gets to compete there
in tampa i love it i'm all this is what
football's all about
it's about competing and still seeing
the guys that you went to to battle with
every day
hanging out can't wait to take a picture
with them and just say hello i've missed
them how much of a factor can derek
henry be coming back from what he came
back from and then you dive right into a
playoff game
oh i i mean listen it i've always told
people this about derek henry they
always say like rate running backs
nobody why don't you ever talk about
derek here i was like he's not a running
back he's a unicorn
you'll never see that again you'll never
see anyone six three 250 pounds that big
that fast playing the football so
it's late it's still late in the year
and he's had a couple weeks of practice
which he should be good to go he may
have a little rust early in the game but
this is the thing
if the cincinnati bengals don't stop his
feet early if you don't get him to like
stutter his steps within the first
couple yards of the line of scrimmage
you don't have a long day because he's
just going to run downhill that's all
he's going to do is just keep running
downhill and by the time the game's over
he'll break a long one um i know his
foot injury is a tough one but
you know with with the way you know
technology is and surgeries and guys we
saw champions came back from achilles in
like six months
like
he'll be fine and to me he's gonna be
he's gonna be a handful in the playoffs
he's gonna be a handful not only he's
gonna be a handful aj brown will be a
handful and julio is gonna show up as
well in a timely situation i guarantee
it because they don't they don't need
julio but he gives them that like you go
a single you're just gonna cover julio
one-on-one okay well he's gonna get a
jump ball here so uh the addition of
derek henry in that running game uh is
gonna be
something that teams are gonna have to
deal with in cincinnati's first up with
will tom brady know your name if he sees
you
come on come on man
are you kidding me you don't think me
and tom meantime we're from the same
area we've talked
someone knows me okay i just i you know
like that just i'm just curious
no man see now you know see you you you
you act as if i just you know i just
call games on on radio for the rams and
then i i i work for nfl network as if we
weren't peers
you know there was one time there's a
story one time i was working at the nfl
they were playing the giants and tom
looked me in my eyes and he said maurice
how have you been and i went to tom like
hey man how you been
and you want to hear a funny story about
it you know you want to know why tom
knows me more than anything
tom's uncle
chris
was my principal in high school so tom
really know me me and tom are kind of
like that you know we're we're kind of
close
closer than you would think numb you
know we got family ties my apologies
okay i'm just trying to make sure you
know that's and then all these football
stuff he don't know me regardless but we
got family ties yeah different by the
way what what size is your neck
i don't know man i'm trying to lose it
though i think it was at one point it
was like 18 and a half 19.
so i'm trying to get you know to regular
size what's a regular neck what size is
a regular neck uh probably 15 16.
okay so i'm gonna try to get down there
i'm gonna try to get you know i may want
i may even get skinnier than that i
might try to go to like a 12. how do you
how do you lose weight in your neck
uh well i think it's you know what you
eat
and doing a lot of neck exercises
possibly
i i think you go from
from traps to ears you don't really have
a neck
you know i was i and i tell people this
i was bred for football
you know some people are bred for other
things
your boy
i was built i was creating a lab in my
mother's lab
to play football what's your official
height and weight
uh like right now or like when i played
playing weight playing weight
oh oh i was like 5'7 208
between 208 and 215.
oh
you seem to play bigger than that
uh again like derek henry i was a
unicorn you know you can't just put
his running backs you know what i mean
i know what it's like to be a unicorn in
the game
all right well good luck uh you know i i
hope you and tom get to uh renew old
acquaintances there and uh always great
to hear from you
uh always good to hear from you as well
i appreciate it and hey go rams thank
you that's mojo maurice jones drew nfl
network analyst at mjd